[Music]
first things first
who was the I guess most natural fighter
because the Fighting's were so intense
and I know you guys had some crazy
training so just who was the most
natural at it off time between you guys
Oh most nitrified between us I mean you
can say means I mean chat was pretty
like you know he's pretty athletic man
he's like the cop where he's like you
know he's very limber and very like his
martial artists is definitely that he's
been training that for for a long time
he's got that under his belt you know
and I'm you know and some more of the
obviously the boxing training I did with
Creed you know I lived as a fighter so I
kind of learned that but then also you
know now playing sports II play sports I
mean we're pretty boy okay we're not mad
I'll say for the ladies we're not mad at
the stills we saw lots of shirtless
photos no matter okay not matter okay I
meant yeah we met I was there a little
bit of a competition to say okay he's
not gonna today no I feel like you know
I'm a naturally competitive person you
know and I honestly I just wanted to
achieve the look that I really needed to
get for for kill monger I'd like weed me
and Chad we didn't really train together
you know everybody was kind of doing
their own homework and building their
characters and and getting into getting
into the role the best the best they
could individually and then we all kind
of gotten you know on something
assembled and we came together and did
what we had to do obviously there's a
lot of choreography and you know fight
training and stuff like that but yeah I
mean think it's a natural competition
and wanna do want to be physically you
know intimidating I wasn't going for
like the the ripped boxer looking that I
kind of wanted
more you know just beef you're heavier
more more and more intimidating on this
one if I could sew up kill monger in the
sense I think it would be there's a thin
line between misunderstood and madman as
I'm taking that you know yeah that's an
awesome sound buddy yeah that's great
yeah I felt like one minute he had his
foot over on this side the next minute
he had his foot over here and I read
where you said you've you called him
like a grounded villains I think you
understand where he's coming from I
think it's a little bit when you watch
it you understand but he has raised
truth without a doubt yeah I think of
villains agenda is deeply impacted by
their backstory their upbringing their
history you know and I said kill mongers
was systemic oppression you know that's
what he grew up in in the states you
know he didn't know his dad got killed
taken away from him was murdered his mom
you know got murdered as well you know
foster care product of environment
product product of the system and had
this rage the only way he kind of saw
his way out was to go equip yourself
train yourself and and and take over you
know so yeah I think it's a mixture of
all that there's Michael tap into a
little bit of that like I think it's a
black man in America
it'd be hard not to yeah so I think you
know even though he has this by any
means necessary mentality he's a product
of that what you know what kind of
America made him but you also understand
the child's point of view also and
that's what I think the quality is a
great villain or antagonist will have is
you can empathize with them you see
where they're coming from you understand
where his rages and I think the child
way and kill monger kind of the same
person yeah you know they care about the
same things they just have two totally
different ways about going about getting
it and to see kind of where they go from
Genesis to revelations and at that
moment to see where they both come as
and adversaries or whatever you want to
call I mean it blew my mind
dealing with identity you know that
conversation between African Americans
and African you know that disconnect
we're definitely this movie you know
drawn a bridge between these two
cultures to start a conversation that I
think people didn't even realize needed
to be had and I think that's that's you
know super powerful I mean I think
anybody that's kind of you know any
country any ethnicity that ever
experienced any type of like systemic
oppression and feeling helpless and
wanting to do something to to better the
situation I think they're gonna you know
understand the frustration and rage of
kill mongering and moments you know
obviously isn't he's an extreme version
of that but at the same time you know
you know being yeah yeah yeah early
reviews are coming in okay some of the
ones that I've read and they're very
positive okay say that kill monger is
one of the best villains in Marvel
Comics in a Marvel comic universe um Wow
okay cool no you were a bit nervous last
night because you said you you really
were trying to bring something different
yes guys yes and I I was like how the
hell am I gonna be empathetic for the
villain like you can understand why he
feels the way he feels he's speaking the
truth
the goal was honestly meant to build a
character that you know would entertain
you you know educate you inspire and
also you know scare you a little bit you
know and I kind of wanted to like hit
those layers and you know try to make it
as grounded as possible and then for the
first time for me playing a character
like that obviously you want to take you
you know you
put your best foot forward and try to
you know shoot for the moon you know
hopefully we got something that reaches
somewhere why don't you want to come
back to the superhero a universe because
you did fantastic more and I noticed
your first time playing a pilla but why
did you feel like okay I can go back and
do this again and I want to because I
love that space I'm not gonna let a
project that you know for whatever
reason you know didn't turn out like I
wanted to stop me from enjoying the
things that I things that I personally
enjoy you know acting in that space
loving you know fantasy and sci-fi and
you know comic books and Marvel I loved
all that stuff and then I get a phone
call from my director that I trust and
he tells me hey Mike you wanna you know
I'm saying play a villain you know do
Black Panther and have that conversation
it's the easy easy yes let your mind you
doing this and I was like I could
whatever let's go and then from that
moment I started growing my hair and
getting in shape and training so it was
it was a it was an easy decision for me
when you start shooting Creed too soon
you know it's uh we're set for the
things given they release November 21st
of this year next year no this year
mm-hmm so we're gonna try that which I
watch how to get that one done and
they're locked and loaded for people is
the right man without a doubt man he's a
super talented thoughtful prepared you
know right in with the film school with
Ryan they know each other they have a
rapport you know and if you know Kugler
cosines obviously because it's his his
baby it's his machines thing it's thing
that he kind of created obviously
inspired by it you know you know sly and
and in the world of rocky but he was the
perfect person to come in and kind of
take over the reins and so we're getting
everything you know in tip-top shape and
yeah we don't we don't get this thing
going pretty soon and Crete do like
rocky could we have three we go I mean
it does the world won't be here as long
as the people who have us so you like
we're we know we're gonna try to you
know keep this thing going
[Music]